[Musique]
il hors de question pour nous de
défendre quelques privilèges que ce soit
basée sur un privilège de classe aux
seuls étudiants
c'est pour ça que l'hélice est relue
aujourd'hui avance les mots d'ordre de
rétablissement des sourcils certes mais
aussi extension du sursis à tous les
jeunes que ce soit les jeunes apprentis
les jeunes travailleurs en cours de
formation professionnelle et se bat pour
le libre choix de la date
d'incorporation pour tous les jeunes
est ce que cette bataille n'est pas
aussi un peu dirigé contre le service
militaire
ça dépend il ya certains camarades qui
sont pour une abrogation totale d'un
service militaire d'autres qui disent
puisqu'on te donne un fusil apprends à
te servir mais ces divergences cela
n'entre pas en ligne de compte
en ce moment il ya un mouvement lycéen
uniquement dirigée contre la loi debré
pour son agresseur précisément pourquoi
en ce moment alors que la loi debré date
de 1970 pour deux raisons la première
c'est que la loi debré n'est rentrer en
application au 1er janvier 73 on n'a pas
perdu de temps fort peu le seconde ce
qu'il a fallu prendre faire prendre
conscience au lycée elle ce qu'était
cette radio
[Musique]